david bonjour alors les enseignants sont
ils au rendez vous il a écouté amira est
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est d'abord que
la manifestation était interdite par la
police les enseignants ont dû se
contenter d'un rassemblement ici rue du
bac près du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
un important dispositif de sécurité a
été mise en place autour des enseignants
vous le voyez derrière moi plusieurs
syndicats sont venus protester et
réclamer davantage de moyens notamment
la création de poste pour assurer les
mesures sanitaires imposées par le
gouvernement
plus de postes pour dispatcher au mieux
les élèves et faire respecter la
distanciation sociale une colère
partagée à part les enseignants du lycée
et ceux du supérieur pour les lycéens
l'inquiétude est de mise et de volonté
est liée à la crainte d'une année
amputer pour les élèves est déjà privé
d'épreuve commune du bac par jean michel
blanquer r les annonces de limitation du
brassage d'élèves en autorisant les
cours à distance sont jugées
insuffisantes
le passage au contrôle continu également
et qualifiés donc chez eugène par la
plupart des professeurs pour les élèves
du lycée
une grève est nationale qui veut une
fois de plus éducation nationale devant
ses responsabilités car ces
revendications datent de bien avant
cette crise sanitaire du commis 19
david à merci pour toutes ces précisions